bonjour aux requins losc ouanane merci
de répondre à nos questions en direct
sur arte france ce matin les bureaux de
vote ouvrent à 7h heure locale au pérou
il est 4 heures en ce moment à lima
évidemment donc pas encore d'estimation
des deux tendances mais en terme de
participation à quoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre droit en principe est simple
parce que c'est un pays où le vote est
obligatoire et on peut suivre des
amendes mais et on n'est pas bien
évidemment sur de cette situation c'est
ce à quoi on peut s'attendre
probablement c'est aussi à des résultats
très serrés parce qu'il sait que c'est
ça qui montrent tous les tous les
sondages effectués au cours des
dernières semaines - pedro castillo
keiko fujimori de candidats de style
caractéristique selon les derniers
sondages pedro castillo serait
légèrement devant mais comme vous l'avez
dîner deux candidats sont au coude à
coude
est ce que ça veut dire que la société
péruvienne est divisée oui divisé et
mêmes représenter si vous regardez les
résultats les élections qu ai-je été
récemment c'était le premier tour
d'élection présidentielle élections
parlementaires le style hâtive vous
arrive et il ya un grain et papillon
n'est ce pas dépêcher dans l'électorat
et il faut rappeler que peu de cardio et
est passé en deuxième tour avec presque
nulle part à 19 pour le centre de
l'ensemble et des suffrages et keiko
fujimori est la deuxième donc est ainsi
pendant ces 2e tour a eu de très spécial
c'est disons pas été partagée par six et
tabitha de 10 pouces en 800 ça veut dire
que c'est lui qui sera élu n'aura pas
une véritable
j timité une véritable représentativité
de l'ensemble du peuple péruvien c'est
ça la disons que un principe disons
maintenant un deuxième tour on va voir
les résultats
51 49 ou peut-être des finances du mcee
on n'en sait rien mais là il évidemment
mais d'un autre côté et qui font le lit
chine au premier tour et ce n'était pas
des forces majoritaire et puissante très
éparpillée en avril on a élu les par le
goût et la wii en gras ce qui fait que
peut-être que le résultat de l'élection
présidentielle deuxième tour certaines
activités comme vous dites au vainqueur
mais en même temps et crac des prémices
tremblements une crise de gouvernance
démocratique parce que et il faut voir
comme aux passionnés par le monde pour
les lois etc
quelle coalition s'établit pour le
moment où on voit que et les autres
forces de gauche est plus modérée cas si
son parti le pérou livre ce sont plutôt
ses candidats et de castillon alors que
les photos des doigts que le staff
technique s'est rangé derrière quelque
optimisme a été assez factuel et qui est
déjà une candidate connu puisqu'il a été
candidate malheureuse d'élections dès
2011 ou à gagner la serbie on m'a là où
les électrons dès 2015 les tpg qui est
qui a été les vainqueurs
dans les deux cas ces candidats et même
poursuivi pour des affaires éventuelle
des corruptions et on vous l'avait
mentionné au delà de la politique
intérieure des affaires de corruption
à quoi est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre en
termes de politique internationale en
cas de succès de l'un ou de l'autre
disons que c'est pas si facile que ça dd
dis ça parce qu on a déjà pas mal des
doutes sur la la
le réalisme des propositions des uns des
autres que ce qui pourrait en fait
politique nationale mais si on ne
regarde maintenant l'alignement les
différents acteurs internationaux par
rapport à aux deux candidats
on voit bien que c'est ce qui explique
la la droite disant la plus dure au
centre du continent latino-américain
l'ancien président uribe par exemple la
colombie ou d'autres pensent également
brésiliens sont plutôt rangée de reiko
fujimori alors qu on pourrait penser que
le venezuela des mcdo ou des forces de
gauche et pays s'est dit plutôt enclin à
soutenir pedro castillon mais pour ce
qui est des grandes puissances
internationales pour le moment et ça a
été très discret de ces différents pays
et le pérou va devoir composer quand
même dans ses rapports avec les
différents acteurs de la scène
internationale puisque c'est un pays
minier spectateurs très important
énergétiques et minières vers l'asie
notamment vers la chine et donc il ya
des liens les importations et puis les
dents l'émissaire américain est avec
disons l'importance qu'accordent les
états unis dans cette heure-là des états
unis qui pour le moment sont très
concentrés et donc point d'interrogation
il faut voir ce que décide par exemple
aussi posons pédérastie dow gagne et qui
décide et concrétiser ses décisions de
lignières énergétique
et bien si cela suscite des réactions
des compagnies internationales
pour le moment c'est trop tôt pour
trancher ou plutôt gris clair sur ça
ce qui est intéressant c'est que pour y
être confronté à une nouvelle étape de
son évolution
même la crise sanitaire pays d'une
grande stabilité économique
il est touché et sur mon expérience
excelle également sous les imbéciles à
merci merci
carlos menem d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur des universités spécialiste
en sciences économiques et vous êtes le
vice-président de l'institut des
amériques on le rappelle les bureaux de
vote ouvrent à 7h heure locale dans
trois heures donc du côté de lima